[Music]
what's going on guys summer has come to
an end but don't be alarmed fall is here
and we have cool fall movies
blockbusters some undiscovered little
gems and a lot of stuff to talk about
one quick clarifier this is the fall
movie preview but we're taking it right
to the end of the year cuz we talked
about it and it just made good sense to
do it that way alright so we got a
couple of awesome movie buffs to talk
about it with first she's a
correspondent for Fandango and you know
her from screen junkies plus Alicia
Malone like it so excited to talk about
these movies so excited talk about these
movies with you and I'd love to welcome
back to the show he is an associate
editor for nerdist.com
welcome back Kyle Anderson hello I'm
excited that summers done we're looking
forward to the fall where we have a lot
of Oscar movies smaller movies more
thoughtful movies and some big ones
let's get a couple the big ones out of
the way right off the bat I'm looking
forward to as everyone is rogue one okay
a Star Wars story what do you think of
the early stuff that we've seen regards
to rogue one
I think the trailer looks fantastic oh
the reports are saying it's going to be
a war movie it does look like a spinoff
from the Star Wars story and Felicity
Jones I think she's going to kill it as
this warrior this is
I'm excited it seems like Gareth Edwards
is trying to shoot it in a different way
kind of you know do 360 sets and kind of
ever do everything handheld to give it
more life that a lot of the Star Wars
movies have I think that'll give it you
know a different edge I'm excited for
some Darth Vader I'm just wondering how
much of a derp are we gonna get in this
movie I just got my vader buzz on
another huge one that we're looking
forward to fantastic beasts and where to
find them to think years ago um naive me
thought oh there's gonna be no more
Harry Potter and welcome back to the
universe a new harry potter book is upon
us so yeah i just think that the period
setting and especially in new york i
think that'll be really interesting and
we cool to see a prequel without any of
like the major players like obviously
they're gonna talk a little bit about
Dumbledore but like we don't know any of
the new characters I think that'll be a
lot of fun there's absolutely nothing to
worry about
and one more Marvel is giving us their
second film this year Doctor Strange
Kyle what do you hear about it what do
you think of what we've seen so far it
looks really interesting to me I'm most
excited for to not look like all the
other Marvel movies I feel like it's got
kind of darker tone to and it definitely
feels a little bit more ethereal a
little more magical or more fun
hopefully this doesn't make any sense
I'm excited and Scott Derrickson as a
director is known for horror so I think
it's a good fit for that title
absolutely so we hit some of the big
tent poles of the season but now I want
to hear from you guys what are some of
the things that you're really looking
forward to some of the maybe smaller
movies or less huge box-office
blockbuster style films Alicia let's
start with you
la-la-land is one of most anticipated
for this year because of a couple of
reasons namely it's directed by Damien
Chazelle who did whiplash which is one
of the most brilliant films in the last
few years yes
now he's teaming up with Ryan Gosling
and Emma Stone he always make a great
pair on screen and the trailer for this
movie just looks so beautiful
[Music]
it's a musical it looks very dreamlike
and it's about a jazz penis - falls in
love with a dancer and it's all set in
Los Angeles and it just looks gorgeous
thanks Kyle
the last several Halloween seasons have
been real relaxed in the horror movie
department or at least good ones so I'm
really excited for Blair Witch to be
coming out or as I thought it was called
for a good long way of the woods I'm a
big Adam Wingard fan I've liked all the
movies that I've seen of his so far and
so I was really excited for this movie
and then when it was revealed at Comic
Con that it was actually a Blair Witch
movie I got even more excited do you
believe in the stories about the Blair
Witch
I think he's doing some interesting
things with the genre and hopefully
it'll be a better found footage than the
last like nine we've had for sure uh
cool Alicia another one I can't wait for
is arrival by Denis Villeneuve and he's
the same director who did in sendees and
prisoners and Sicario no enemy and each
of those films are so different from the
previous one this looks completely
different again it's a sci-fi movie
about aliens coming to Earth and then
Amy Adams is this linguistics expert who
tries to communicate with them that's a
proper introduction trailer looks
beautiful so I cannot wait for that Kyle
I'm really looking forward to the
accountant I think that has such a great
ad campaign so far especially that first
trailer with the Radiohead song in it
he has highly advanced cognitive skills
it's an interesting kind of
juxtaposition from like Bruce Wayne Ben
Affleck to this kind of like creepy solo
murderer slash math whiz kind of guy I
think it'll be an interesting movie for
sure the cast of that film is off the
charts got Ben Affleck Jon Bernthal John
Lithgow Kendrick yeah yeah absolutely
looking forward to that
Alicia what's sticking with the
Affleck's a film that I got to see at
Sundance is called Manchester by the sea
and that will definitely be talked about
for Oscars in terms of Casey Affleck
performance because he is incredible not
gonna bother you I just sit there until
you calm down alright I'm calming it
would you please just go away no it's
not a fun movie to watch but it's very
heartbreaking it's super emotional it's
about a father who is dealing with some
demons from the past I won't reveal what
that is because it's such a surprise
when you see it and it packs an
emotional punch yeah and that's why I'm
a really strong writer director Ken
Lonergan who's you can count on me with
such a beautiful thoughtful film that
was the first I saw of Mark Ruffalo yeah
that film so yeah I loved his tone and
style ken Lonergan yes great great I'm
glad to hear that hey Kyle I never
thought I would be this guy again
but I love any and all Disney movies
that come out now the last several have
been great so I'm really looking forward
to Moana it's a new kind of vision a new
place a new setting a new type of story
that they haven't really done before and
I like that they're taking chances you
know a hundred years into their
producing move for sure Alisha a movie
I'm really hopeful is great is the girl
on the train because I loved the book
it's just an easy read so much fun I
couldn't put it down it's very similar
kind of tone to gone girl I didn't
picture Emily Blunt when I read the book
in terms of that character but she
always brings such a brilliant
performance I saw her I saw her from the
train so the trailer looks a little
crazy at the moment but I think that
they've done a good job in not revealing
the story because it has a lot of twists
and turns so I'm really hoping that this
one turns out to be as good as the book
all right you guys already mention a
bunch that's got me super pumped for the
fall movie season but there are a few
more so I'm just going to throw them out
there see if you have any thoughts see
what we think won the Sundance Darling
sold for the highest amount of money
seventeen and a half million I believe
that any film has ever sold for its
Sundance
Birth of a Nation yeah it's been in the
headlines lightly for different reasons
yeah it's actually Sundance it made a
huge amount of buzz learned your lesson
oh yes no I hear it's a really powerful
story it was one of those films that I
wanted to get into it the screening and
then by the time another screening
rolled out it was packed full of people
because there was so much buzz around
this movie Mel Gibson's back with
hacksaw Ridge directing one of his first
features in a while Andrew Garfield is
getting early Oscar buzz for this film
have either of you heard anything in
particular I mean nothing in particular
but it was really kind of taken by the
trailer like it sounded like I was just
gonna be another war movie but I like
the idea of talking about people who are
in the war but are not fighting like
conscientious objectors butter in the
war well everybody else has taken life
I'm gonna be saving it that's gonna be
my way to start it's a fascinating story
and the fact that he wouldn't even pick
up a gun that's gonna make for so much
tension I think in the movie absolutely
Oh Michael Keaton has a starring role in
the upcoming story of McDonald's founder
Ray Kroc and the founder are you excited
for more Keaton yeah I've last two years
have been like prime Keaton and I've
been waiting for him to make a comeback
so like another starring role I thought
he was sort of robbed from the Oscar a
couple of years ago so hopefully this
kind of makes up for that maybe he'll
get nominated again and I'd love to see
Batman win an Oscar that glorious name
McDonald's I have it you don't have it
you sure about that Tim Burton's back in
some whimsical territory miss
peregrine's home for peculiar children
not to be confused with Professor Xavier
home for gifted children yeah yeah this
is Tim Burton back in like you said the
territory that he should be I got to see
a couple of scenes from this film it
does look very burton-esque
okay so it looks like it could be a
return to the kind of Edward
Scissorhands type form because her
abilities
live in places like this I'm gonna start
calling this film emo x-men and they
were very much during the press junket
trying to be like with nothing like
x-men this is not a superhero movie but
it's about kids dealing with their own
powers
it looks cool day one last one a lot of
gamers out there want to know any
thoughts on Assassin's Creed huh can it
break the street can't break the street
oh poor videogame Lee not sure I mean I
love Michael Fassbender of course he is
such a great actor but I have seen a
little bit of the film and it wasn't
finished so the effects weren't complete
but I wasn't impressed with what I saw
not being a gamer though so maybe people
who enjoy the game will might like it a
lot more but for me I just couldn't
figure out much about the story or what
kind of tone it's supposed to be I I'm
not a gamer either but from what I know
about the story certainly of the film
they're kind of sticking pretty close to
the structure of the game which is you
know you start in the future and you go
back in the past kind of thing which I
feel like I just start in the past like
you know you don't need to be the player
necessarily in this so hopefully it'll
be good but like I'm yeah yeah we'll see
we work in the dark just sort of the
light way processes you guys have gotten
me properly excited for the fall movie
season are you excited for the fall how
many movies are you going to see what
are you most excited for was there
anything we left off the list that
you're looking forward to let us know in
the comments below I have to thank my
awesome panel I could not ask for two
more learning movie Minds to let us know
what to look forward to
Alicia Malone great seeing you as always
Kyle Anderson thanks for being here sir
and thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm how rotten it kept me up on
Twitter bye bye from the writer
directors who brought you this movie and
not much else comes the game-changing
horror film that made back 20,000
percent of its budget changed the face
of the genre and pissed off a generation
of film school nerds who wish they
thought of it
the Blair Witch Project